non-natural non-tested federations of
bodybuilding what is your guess or
knowledge even about the sort of health
impact that these guys are having in
order to achieve at the absolute top
level like it's hard to quantify but in
general I would say if you are pushing
the envelope Full Tilt in the open
bodybuilding division you would be lucky
to make it past
45 years old if you are doing Full Tilt
bodybuilding the entire time you mean
like you'd be dead at 45 potentially
yeah like if you were going hard as from
like Teenage Hood to 45
blasting every single offseason weighing
up to 300 pounds you know cutting down
to you know 260 270 stand on stage you
know sometimes less it depends on
depends on the height of the guy
whatever I think the top guys at the
sport like I would be impressed if they
came out
at 45 years old retired and were like
still live the normal duration of life
and is that common to if you have the
right genetics and you get picked up and
you start doing Junior shows as soon as
someone hits 18 19 20 21 is that the
sort of beginning of their use of
steroids uh in general a lot of guys
will
realize quite quickly that everyone
they're competing against even as low as
the entry-level shows are using [ __ ] and
then they feel compelled to do so as
well because to be competitive among
those guys
it's just like uh necessary evil
unfortunately there depending on your
genetics you might be able to get
somewhat far but once you get to the pro
ranks like you're not gonna win top
shows at all if you're natural it's just
impossible so let's say that someone
hasn't dropped out at 45 I'm gonna guess
in terms of health health outcomes uh
being able to live a normal life which
isn't assisted with a ton of drugs on
the outside is at a risk as well
yeah so and let me sort of circle back
to the the dying at 45 thing that's like
the war if somebody is Full Tilt
maintaining these high body weights
perpetually and doing it for you know 10
20 years and probably predisposed yeah
like some of these some guys will drop
in their 20s when they are in this uh in
Pro bodybuilding talking about uh Boston
Lloyd last night yeah obviously people
will use him as a outlier because his
use of drugs was so extreme and just
such uh
um he often would neglect even getting
Diagnostics to assess things and he just
I don't know like again I don't have all
the Insight on exactly what he was doing
or not doing but it seemed
uh it was a lot of uh
some mental issues around the the
compulsion to take certain things that
he knew was probably unhealthy but
anyway the bodybuilders that are trying
to live the lifestyle though and are
eating copious amounts of foods taking
the drugs they need to maintain the high
body weights like it's just it's just
unhealthy in general like there's
nothing Fitness or health conducive
about it at the end of the day that in
Esports too dangerous yeah obviously
magnitude's different in terms of danger
but I mean like one is uh yeah
physically and mentally pretty
problematic and then the Esports thing
you know it was just the second thing I
could think of underneath that makes
sense to me man um there's obviously
more sports like obviously people are
gonna be like what about football people
crashing into each other with their
helmets on and stuff UFC like obviously
there are things worse it was just a
quick remark but I think in terms of the
um like the byproduct of Simply
preparing for the sport it's pretty
difficult to say that there's anything
which is which gives you worse Health
outcomes I'll be interested to know like
the act of actually preparing is not
necessarily unhealthy when you are in
the middle of uh off season you're
training hard you're doing hopefully a
decent getting a decent step count still
eating your macro and micronutrients but
it's just when you get to the the super
physiological range of muscle tissue
that your body's supposed to hold it's
literally fighting back against you to
try and not hold as much size you're
using drugs that your body was never
meant to process it the amounts you're
injecting into yourself but you're
bypassing all the regulating feedback
systems such as Hamming yourself with
super physiological amounts
um like it's just anything above that
threshold you are getting into
escalating risk territory and like
obviously the natural bodybuilding in
itself other than the extreme weight
cutting and water depletion potentially
the act of natural bodybuilding is not
unhealthy like it's a very healthy thing
and I don't think the the general
bodybuilding shouldn't dissuade people
because it's unhealthy it's just the
drug use the excessive body weights and
the excessive eating they have to do to
achieve those body weights with the drug
use that is the most problematic so
you're saying that there is a a ceiling
to muscle carrying capacity that bodies
have and that you start to bounce off a
particular limiter because I've always
thought like why is it that you don't
have bigger variance in how particular
bodybuilders at the absolute top look on
stage like why don't you have people
that are
another 50 pounds bigger than everybody
else there sort of is some people like
there are have you ever seen big Grammy
I have yeah he could be classified as
yeah and is that um with somebody like
that he's maybe got like a what a like a
higher carrying capacity his body's
tolerance for being able to not destroy
muscle is greater than everybody else's
maybe uh it depends but there's
definitely like at the end of the day
it's a genetic thing because there's no
way he's necessarily working harder than
a guy who's coming in 10th Place maybe
maybe he is but there are a lot of guys
I know who work their [ __ ] asses off
and will never beat him even if they
probably work harder I'm not saying he
doesn't work hard but just in general
there are certain people no matter what
they do or how much drugs they take they
will never beat him even if they double
his drug dose it's just the genetic
predisposition it could be more muscle
fiber content from when he was
developing as a like literally in the
womb like that some of that stuff you
can't really compensate for just with
more drugs because you only have so much
infrastructure to build off of and
induce hypertrophy and so many muscle
cells that you can then try and do
things with and if you don't have that
infrastructure to get to the big Ramy
size like
it's just not going to happen but this
is like such a hyper outlier scenario
anyways like no one at the end of the
day the takeaway for the average person
who can you know relate to this because
we're not bodybuilders the people
watching probably aren't you know
top-tier bodybuilders so
um I try to keep the the context of this
more relatable for the the average
person like ultimately drugs at Super
physiological super physiological doses
there's no situation in which it is uh
you're not going to have some trade-off
for its use essentially there's always a
give and take when it comes to Peds
what's happening people if you enjoyed
that then press here for the full
unedited episode and don't forget to
subscribe
peace
[Music]